OPERATOR: The following content
is provided under a
Creative Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Last lecture we were
talking about classes,
and object-oriented programming,
and we're going
to come back to it today.
I'm going to remind you, we were
talking about it because
we suggested it is a really
powerful way of structuring
systems, and that's really why
we want to use it, It's a very
common way of structuring
systems. So today I'm going to
pick up on a bunch of more
nuanced, or more complex if
you like, ways of leveraging
the power of classes.
But we're going to see a bunch
of examples that are going to
give us a sense.
I'm going to talk about
inheritance, we're going to
talk about shadowing, we're
going to talk about iterators.
But before get to it, I want to
start by just highlighting,
sort of, what was the
point of classes?
So I'll remind you.
A class, I said, was basically
a template for an
abstract data type.
And this was really to drive
home this idea of modularity.
I want the ability to say, I've
got a set of things that
naturally belong together,
I'm going to cluster them
together, I want to treat it
like it's a primitive, I want
to treat it like it's a float
or an int or a string.
Is this going to be a point
or a segment or something
different like that.
So it's really a way, as I
said, of just trying to
cluster data together.
And this is a notion of
modularity slash abstraction
where I'm treating them
as primitives.
But the second thing we talked
about is that we also have a
set of methods, using the
special name method because
we're talking classes.
But basically functions that are
designed to deal with this
data structure.
We're trying to group those
together as well.
So we cluster data
and methods.
Second key thing we said was,
in the ideal case, which
unfortunately Python isn't, but
we'll come back to that,
in the ideal case, we would have
data hiding, and by data
hiding, which is sort of a
version of encapsulation, what
we meant was that you could
only get to the internal
pieces of that data structure
through a proscribed method.
Proscribed meaning it's
something I set up.
So data hiding saying, you would
only access the parts
through a method.
And as we said, unfortunately
Python does not enforce this.
Meaning that I could create one
of these data structures,
ideally I'd have a method, that
I'm going to see some
examples of that I used to get
the parts out, unfortunately
in Python you could take the
name the instance dot some
internal variable you'll
get it back.
It is exposed.
And this is actually just
not a good idea.
So I suggested in my very bad
humor, that you practice
computational hygiene and you
only use appropriate methods
to get the parts out.
OK didn't laugh the joke last
time, you're not going to
laugh at it this time,
I don't blame you.
All right, and then the last
piece of this is that we said
the class is a template.
When we call that class,
it makes an instance.
So class is used to make
instances, meaning particular
versions, of that structure,
and we said inside the
instances we have a
set of attributes.
Internal variables, methods,
that are going to belong to
that structure.
OK, so with that in mind, here's
what I want to do.
I'm going to show you a set of
examples, and I want to warn
you ahead of time, the code
handout today is a little
longer than normal because we
want to build essentially an
extended example of a sequence
of examples of classes.
We're going to see the idea,
of which we're gonna talk
about, of inheritance or
hierarchy, in which we can
have classes that are
specializations of other classes.
We're gonna see how we can
inherit methods, how we can
shadow methods, how we can use
methods in a variety of ways.
So this is a way of suggesting
you may find it more
convenient to put notes on the
code handout rather than in
your own notes.
Do whatever you like, but I
just wanted to alert you,
we're going to go through a
little more code than normal.
So, the little environment
I'm going to build is an
environment of people.
I'll build a simple little
simulation of people.
So I'm going to start off with
the first class, which I've
got up on the screen, and it's
on your handout as well, which
is I'm going to build an
instance, or a class rather,
of persons.
I'm going to draw a diagram,
which I'm gonna try and see if
I can do well, over here, of
the different objects we're
going to have. So I've got, a
class, and by the way a class
is an object.
Instances are also objects,
but classes are objects.
We're gonna see why we want
that in a second.
Because I'm gonna build
an object, sorry a
class, called a person.
Now, let's walk through some
of the pieces here.
The first one is, there's
something a little different.
Remember last time we had that
keyword class and then a name,
that name, in this case, person
says this is the name
for the class, and then we
would have just had the
semicolon and a bunch
of internal things.
Here I've got something in
parens, and I want to stress
this is not a variable.
All right, this is not a
def, this is a class.
I'm going to come back to it,
but what this is basically
saying is that the person class
is going to inherit from
another class, which in this
case is just the built-in
Python object class.
Hold on to that thought, it's
going to make more sense when
we look at a little more
interesting example, but I
want to highlight that.
All right now, if we do this,
as I said before, we can
create a version of a
person, let me just
call it per, person.
OK?
And what we said last time is,
when we wanted to create an
instance inside of this class
definition, we've got one of
those built-in things
called init.
I'm gonna again remind you, some
of the methods we have,
Underbar underbar init is going
to be the thing that
creates the instance.
Actually slightly misspeaking,
actually Python creates the
instance, but it's one thing
that fills it in.
So in this case, I'm going to
give it 2 arguments: Frank
Foobar Now, you might have said,
wait a minute, init here
has 3 arguments: self, family
name, and first name.
So again, just to remind you,
what we said happens here is
that when I call this
class, person,
I'm creating an instance.
We'll draw a little instance
diagram down here.
I'm going to give
it the name per.
And I should have said inside
of person, we've
got a set of things.
We've got our underbar underbar
init, we've got, what
else do I have up there?
Family name.
And a bunch of other methods,
down to say.
What happens inside of Python
is, when we called the class
definition, person, it creates
an instance, there it is.
Think of it as a pointer to a
spot in memory, and then what
we do is, we call, or find, that
init method, up here, and
we apply it.
And the first argument self,
points to the instance.
So this object here is
what self looks at.
Now you can see what
init's going to do.
It says, oh, inside of self,
which is pointing to here, let
me bind a variable, which was,
can read that very carefully,
it's family underbar name,
to the value I passed
in, which was 4.
Same thing with first name.
OK, so the reason I'm stressing
this is, self we do
not supply explicitly, it is
supplied as pointing to the
instance, it's giving us
that piece of memory.
And that is what then
gets created.
So here's, now, the
instance for per.
OK, and I put a little label
on there, I'm going to call
that an isALink, because it is
an instance of that class.
God bless you.
All right, so once we got this,
let's look at what we
can do with person.
That's why I built
person here.
And as I said, I've
already bound
basically, those two pieces.
If I want to get a value out,
I can give person, or per,
rather, this instance,
a messaging.
In this case I want to get
family, what did I say, family
name out, now, again I want to
stress, what is happening
here? per is an instance,
it's this thing here.
When I say per dot family
name, I'm sending it a
message, in essence what that
does is, it says, from here
it's going to go up the chain to
this class object and find
the appropriate method,
which was family name.
It is then going to apply
that to self, which
points to this instance.
And that allows it, therefore,
is you can see on the code, to
look up under self, what's the
binding for family name, and
print it back up.
So self is always going to point
to the instance I want
and I can use it.
OK what else do we
have in here?
We can get the first name,
that's not particularly
interesting.
We've got 2 other special
methods: that's cmp and str.
All right, cmp is our
comparison method.
And since I, I was about to
say I blew it last time, I
misspoke last time, a wonderful
phrase that
politicians like to use,
I misspoke last time.
Let me clarify again
what cmp will do.
Underbar underbar cmp is going
to be the method you're going
to use to compare two instances
of an object.
Now, let's back up for second.
If I wanted to test equality,
in fact I could use underbar
underbar eq, under under.
It's natural to think about an
equality tester as returning a
Boolean, it's either gonna
be true or false, because
something's either
equal to or not.
In many languages, comparisons
also return Booleans, which is
why I went down this
slippery slope.
For many languages, either it's
greater than or it's not.
But Python is different.
Python use cmp, in fact it has
a built in cmp, which is what
we're relying on here.
Where am I, right there.
And what cmp returns
is 1 of 3 values.
Given 2 objects, it says if the
first one is less than the
second one, it returns -1, if
it's equal it returns 0, if
it's greater than,
it returns 1.
So it allows you this broader
range of comparisons.
And if you think about it,
cmp, you could apply on
integers, you could apply it on
floats, apply it on strings.
So it's overloaded, it has the
ability to do all of those.
And in this case what we're
saying is, given 2 objects,
let's create a tuple of the
first, sorry, family and first
name of ourselves, and other is
another object, family and
first name of that, and then
just use cmp to compare them.
All right, so it's going
to use the base pieces.
OK, so it gives me a way
of doing comparisons.
And str we saw last time as
well, this is cmp does
comparison, and str is our
printed representation.
OK.
So what we've got now, is
a simple little class.
We've also got two
methods there.
I want to look at them, we're
gonna come back to them, but
they start to highlight things
we can do with our classes.
So I've built one simple
version of it
here, which is per.
And notice I've got another
method, right up
here, called say.
And say takes two arguments,
for the moment the second
argument, or the first
argument's, not going to make
a lot of sense, but say takes
two arguments besides itself.
It's going to take another
object to which it's saying
something and the
thing to say.
Since I only have one object
here, I'm going to have person
talk to himself.
You may have met a few
other undergraduates
who have this behavior.
I'll have him talk to himself
and say, just some random
message the faculty members
occasionally worry about.
OK, what does this thing do?
Now you're going to see some
of the power of this.
Again, remember, I'm down here,
I'm sending this the
message say, it's going to go
up the chain to find the say
message in person.
And what does say do, it says
given another object and some
string, it's going to return,
oh, and interesting things,
part of which you can't
see on the screen.
First what it does, is it
gets first name of self.
Remember self is pointing to
this instance, so it's simply
looks up that binding,
which is Frank.
It's going to create a string
in which it adds to that the
family name of self, and then
another thing that says to,
and then ah, I'm now going to
send a message to the other
object, saying give me
your first name.
Going to add that to the second
piece, and you can see
in this case it happens
to be the same
first and family name.
And then at the end of it, which
you can't see here but
you can see in your handout, I
just append the whole string,
so it spits it out.
What's the point of this,
other than I can
get it to say things?
Notice, I can now reference
values of the instance.
But I can also get values
of other instances, by
sending in a message.
And that's why we have that
form right there.
And then it glued
all together.
If you think about this for a
second, you might say, wait a
minute, actually you might
have said wait a minute a
while ago, why am I just using
the variable name there in the
function over here?
Well in fact, I could've used
the function here, first name
open close, right?
It would have done
the same thing.
But because I know I'm inside
the instance, it's perfectly
reasonable to just look
up the value.
OK, I could have, although I
don't want you to do it, have
done the same thing there and
used underbar, sorry, first
name underbar, sorry, first
underbar name, but that's
really breaking this contract
that I want to happen.
I should send the message to
get the method back out.
So again the standard practices
is if you know
you're inside the object, you
can just access the values.
If you're doing it with any
other objects, send it a
message to get it out.
OK, now, that gives you an
ability to say, let's look at
one more example here, and
then we're going to start
building our hierarchy,
which is, that this
person can also sing.
And we've got a little
sing method here.
And notice what it does, it's
going to sing to somebody, I
guess you're part of
the Chorallaries.
You're going to sing something,
and notice what it
does, it's simply going to use
its say method, but add at the
end of whatever's being said,
just tra la la at the end.
So this is now an example of a
method using another method.
Why would you want that?
It's nice modularly.
I have one method that's doing
saying, I have another method
that's just building on it.
So if I have is person sing to
themselves, not a highly
recommended activity, it would
help if I had it sing to
itself, not sing to sing,
sorry about that.
Notice what it does.
Looks like exactly like a say
method, except it's got tra la
la at the end.
Don't worry I'm not going
to sing to you.
I'll simply say the words.
Power of this, other than
the silly examples.
You see how I can access
variables of the instance, how
I can access variables of other
instances, going to come
back to that, and how I can use
versions of my own methods
to implement other methods.
In this case sing is using
say as part of what it
wants to get out.
OK, so we got a simple
little example.
Now, let's start adding some
other pieces to this.
OK, and what do I want to add.
Find my spot here.
OK, we're going to add
an MIT person.
Sorry, machine is -- do
this, let's go down.
OK so I'm going to add
an MIT person.
Look at the code for second.
Aha!
Notice what this says.
MIT person says it inherits
from person.
That is, that's the first thing
in parens up there.
It says, you know, class of
MIT person is person.
What that is saying is, that
this is a specialization of
the person class.
Or another way of saying it is,
we have a super class, in
this case it's person.
And we have a subclass, in
this case its MIT person.
And we're going to walk through
some examples, but
what it says is that that
subclass of MIT person can
inherit the attributes
of the person class.
Can inherit the methods, it
can inherit variables.
OK, what does MIT person do?
Well, here's 1 of the
new things it does.
It has a local variable called
next id num, which is
initially set to 0.
See that up there.
And then it's got some methods,
it's got an init
method, a get id method,
a few other things.
OK, let's run this.
In particular, I go back
down to this one.
Let me just uncomment
this and do it here.
Assuming my machine will do what
I want it to do, which it
really doesn't seem to
want to do today.
Try one more time.
Thank you, yep.
Still not doing it
for me, John.
OK, we type it.
No idea what Python doesn't like
me today, but it doesn't.
So we're gonna define p 1, I've
lost my keyboard, indeed
I have. Try one more time. p 1
MIT person, see how fast I can
type here --
OK, now, let's look at what the
code does, because again
it's going to highlight
some things.
I called MIT person, push this
up slightly, it's going to
create an instance down
here, I called p 1.
And when I would do that,
I'm gonna initialize it.
So I've got, right up here, an
initializer, init for MIT
person, takes in the family
name and the first name.
Notice what it does.
Huh.
It says, if I'm sitting here at
MIT person, I'm going to go
up and inherit from person its
init function and call it.
And what am I calling it on?
I'm calling it on self, which is
pointing to this object, so
I've still got it, and then I'm
then going to apply the
base initialization.
And that does exactly what you'd
expect, which is just
going to create a binding for
family name down here.
As well as some other things.
So this is an example
of inheritance.
MIT person inherits the init
method from person, can get
access to by simply referring
to it, and I
refer to it right there.
And it's take the person class,
get its init and apply
it to my instance plus
those things.
So I'm just using the
same piece of code
Notice the second
thing it does.
It says inside of self, I'm
going to bind the local
variable id name to the value of
next id name in MIT person.
Self is down here, id num,
sorry, not id name.
I'm going to bind that to the
value that I find my going up
to here, which is 0, and having
done that, I simply
increment that value.
OK?
So what has this done?
It says I now have captured in
the class, a local variable
that I can keep track of.
And when I use it, every time I
generate an example, let me
build another one.
I make p 2 another MIT person.
OK, I can do things like saying,
what is the id number
for each of these.
First one is 0, second one is
1, which makes sense, right?
I'm just incrementing
a global variable.
Now, things I want you
to see about this.
Now that I've got a beginning
of a hierarchy, I have this
notion of inheritance.
I can ask a function inside one
class to use a function
from a class that it can reach
by going up the chain.
I just did it there.
I can ask it to go get values
of variables, right, so that
looks good.
What else do we have in
person or MIT person?
Well, we can get the id
number, we just did.
We have a thing to do
with this string.
Notice it's going to print out
something a little different.
In fact, there's a kind
of funky form there.
Which just says, if I want to
print it out, I'm gonna
create, what this says to do is,
I'm gonna create an output
template that has that structure
to it, but where I
see that percent s I'm going to
substitute this value for
the first one, that value
for the second.
So if I say, what is p 1?
It says ok, MIT person
Fred Smith.
On the other hand, if I said,
what is per, which is that
thing I build earlier, it had
a different string method,
which is just print out
person, those pieces.
All right, one last piece
to this and we're
going to add to it.
Suppose I want Fred
to say something.
Say something to Jane.
OK, he said it.
Where's the say method?
OK, Fred is an instance
of an MIT person.
where's the say method?
Well, there isn't one there,
but again, that's where the
hierarchy comes in.
Fred is this object here, I'm
sending it the message say.
That turns into going up the
chain to this object, which is
the class object, and saying
find a say method and apply it
to that instance.
Fudge-knuckle, it ain't here.
Don't worry about it, because
it says if I can't find one
there, I'm going to go up the
chain to this method, sorry to
this class, and look
for a method there.
Which there was one, I
have a say method.
It's going to use
that say method.
Apply to it.
Well, you might say, OK, what
happens if it isn't there?
Well, that's where, remember
I defined person to be an
instance of an object, it will
go up the chain one last time
to the base object in Python
to see is there a
method there or not.
Probably isn't a say method
for an object, so at that
point it's going to raise an
exception or throw an error.
But now you again see this idea
that the inheritance lets
you capture methods.
Now you might say, why not just
put a say method inside
of MIT person?
Well, if you wanted it to do
something different, that
would be the right
thing to do.
But the whole notion here's that
I'm capturing modularity,
I've got base methods
up in my base class.
If I just want to use them I'm
just going to inherit them by
following that chain, if you
like, basically up the track.
OK, so we've got an MIT person,
we can use that.
Let's add a little bit more
to our hierarchy here.
I'm going to create, if
I can do this right, a
specialization of an MIT
person, which is an
undergraduate.
A special kind of MIT person.
All right, so if I go back up
here, even though my thing is
not going to let me do it, let's
build an undergraduate.
OK, there's the class definition
for an undergrad.
We're just starting to see some
of the pieces, right, so
in an undergraduate, where am
I here, an undergraduate.
OK, it's also got an
initialization function.
So if I call undergrad, I'm
gonna make an undergrad here,
again let me go back down here,
line ug 2 it's making
undergrad, Jane Doe.
Now, what happens when I do
the initialization here?
Notice what goes on.
It simply calls the person
initialization method.
All right, so I'm down here.
I'm going to call the person
initialization
method, what did do?
Sorry, the MIT person method,
it calls the person method.
Just walking up the chain,
that's going to do exactly
what I did with all the other
ones, so I now have a family
name and a first name.
So I can, for example,
say family name
and get it back out.
All right?
And then, other things that I
can do, well I can set what
year the person's in, I can
figure out what year they're
in, there's this unfortunate
overflow error if you've hung
around too long, but that's not
going to happen to you.
And I've now got a say method
here, so let's look what
happens if I ask the
undergraduate to say something.
OK, it's not a realistic
dialogue I know, but, what did
this method do?
I asked this object
to do a say.
And notice what it does.
It simply passes it back
up to MIT person.
There's that inheritance
again.
It's saying, I'm going
to have my base
say method say something.
I'm going to say it to a person,
but all I'm going to
do because undergraduates in my
experience, at least, are
always very polite, I'm going to
put "Excuse me but" at the
front of it.
OK, what am I trying
to show you here?
I know the jokes are awful,
but what am I
trying to show you here?
That I can simply pass up
the chain to get it.
In fact, what method does
the final say here?
What class does it come from?
Person class, yes, thank you.
It goes all the way up to
person, right, because MIT
person didn't have a say.
So I can simply walk up the
chain until I find the method
I want to have.
Now this is an example
of shadowing.
Not a great example, but it's
a beginning example of
shadowing, in that this same
method for an undergraduate,
shadows the base say method, it
happens to call it, but it
changes it.
It puts "Excuse me but" at
the front, before it
goes on to do something.
Now again, I could have decided
here to actually copy
what the original say method
did, stitch all the other
things together.
But again, that loses
my modularity.
I'd really to only have to
change it in one place.
So by putting my say method up
in person, I can add these
nuances to it, and it lets
me have something
that has that variation.
If I decide I want to change
what say does, I only have to
change it in one place.
It is in the person class
definition, and everything
else will follow through
for free.
OK, so now I've got an
undergrad, right?
Let's look at a couple
of variations of
what happens here.
So first of all, I can -- yes?
PROFESSOR 2: Shadowing here
is often sometimes called
overriding.
PROFESSOR: Yes, thank you,
because I'm going to do a pure
example of shadowing in
a second, John right.
Also called overriding.
Part of the reason I like the
phrase shadow is, if you think
about it as looking at it from
this direction, you see this
version of init before you see
the other ones, or you see
that version of say, but
it is overriding
the base say example.
OK, so I can say, what does
p 1, sorry, yes, what does
undergrad look like?
And I said wait a minute,
MIT person, not
undergrad, is that right?
Well, where's the str method?
I didn't define one in
undergrad, so it again tracks
up the chain and finds the str
method here, so it's OK
undergrads are MIT people
most the time, so
it's perfectly fine.
OK, now, I have built into this
also these cmp methods.
So I've got two examples.
I've got undergrad, or ug.
And then I've got poor
old Frank Foobar
back there, per person.
So suppose I want
to compare them?
What do you think
happens here?
Compare sounds weird,
right, I compare an
undergraduate to a person.
I don't know what that's doing,
some kind of weird
psychological thing, but what do
you think happens in terms
of the code here
if I run this.
I know it's a little hard
because you got a lot of code
to look at.
Do I have a cmp method
defined somewhere?
Yeah.
So, it's hard to know what it's
going to do, but let's
look at it.
Hmm.
Now sometimes I type things
and I got errors I don't
expect, this one I did expect.
So what happened here?
Well let's talk about what
happens if I do that
comparison I was doing,
what was I doing?
Ug greater than per?
What unwinds into is, I'm going
to send to ug, that
instance, a cmp method.
This is really going to become
something like ug dot under
under cmp under under
applied to per.
I think that's close.
What does that do?
It says starting in ug, I'm
going to look for the first
cmp method I could find, which
is actually sitting here.
I had a cmp method
in MIT person.
If you look at your code,
what does it do?
It looks up the id numbers
to compare them.
Well the, ug has an id number
because it was created along
this chamber.
Remember per over here was
just created as a person.
It doesn't have an id number,
so that's why it complaints.
Ok, happens if I do that?
Compare per to ug.
How many people think
I get an error?
Wow.
How many people think I'm going
to get either true or
false out of this?
A few brave hands.
Why?
Can I ask you, please?
Why do you think I'm going to
get a, doesn't matter whether
it's true or false, why am I
going to have something work
this time that didn't
work last time?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, exactly.
And in case you didn't hear it,
thank you, great answer,
sorry, terrible throw.
In this case I'm using per,
that's the first part, so it's
not symmetric.
It's gonna use per to
do the look up.
And as it was said there, per
over here goes up and finds a
cmp method here which
it can apply.
In that case, it simply looked
at, remember, it took the
tuples of first and last name
which are both defined here,
and did some comparison
on that.
So this is a way of again
pointing out to you that the
things are not always symmetric,
and I have to be
careful about where do
I find the methods as
I want to use them.
Ok?
All right.
Let's add, I'm gonna do
two more classes here.
Let's add one more class, some
people debate whether these
are really people or not, but
we're going to add a class
called a professor.
OK.
Now what am I doing?
I'm creating another version
of class down here.
Which again is an instance, or
a subclass, sorry, not an
instance, a subclass
of an MIT person.
I see that because I built
it to be there.
Again I've got an initialization
that's going to
call the person initialization,
which we know
is going to go up --
I keep saying that -- going
to call the MIT person
initialization, which is going
to go up and call this one.
So again I'm going to be
able to find names.
And I do a couple of other
different things here.
I'm gonna pass in a rank, full
professor, associate
professor, assistant professor,
which I'm just
going to bind locally.
But I'm gonna add one other
piece here, which is I'm gonna
add a little dictionary
on teaching.
So when I create a professor,
I'm gonna associate with it a
dictionary that says, what
have you been teaching?
And then notice the
methods I create.
I've got a method here called
add teaching, takes, obviously
a pointer to the instance.
A term, which will just be
a string, and a subject.
And let's look at what
it does right here.
OK.
In fact the call I'm going to
make, I'm not certain I'm
going to be able to get away
with it, my machine is still
wonderfully broken, all right,
it is, let me just show you
what the calls would
look like.
As you can see here I'm not
going to be able to do them.
But I'm going to add teaching,
as a method call with this
with a string for term,
and a subject number.
What is this going to do?
Yeah, I know I'm just worried if
I restart Python, I may not
be able to pull the thing back
in, so I'm going to try and
wing it, John, and see if
I can make it happen.
Right, what does that
teaching do?
It's got one of those
try except methods.
So what does it say
it's going to do?
It's going to go into the
dictionary associated with
teaching, under the value of
term, and get out a list. And
it's going to append
to the end of the
list the new subject.
So it's going to be stored in
there, is then going to be
term, and a list of what I
taught, in case I teach more
than one thing each term.
It's going to do that, but
notice it's a try.
If in fact there is no term
currently in the dictionary,
started out empty, it's going to
throw an error, sorry, not
throw an error, it's going
to raise an exception.
Which is a key error, in which
case notice what I'm going to
do, I'm not going to treat
it as an error.
I'm simply going to say, in that
case, just start off with
an empty, with an initial list
with just that subject in and
put it in the dictionary.
As I add more things in, I'll
just keep adding things to
this dictionary under
that term.
And if I want to find out what
I'm doing, well I can use get
teaching, which says given the
term, find the thing in the
dictionary under that
term and return it.
If I get an error, I'm going to
raise it, which says there
is nothing for that term, and in
that case I guess I'm just
going to return none.
OK?
And then the other two pieces
we're going to have here, and
we want to look at a little more
carefully, I just wanted
to show you that example, is a
professor can lecture, and a
professor can say something.
Look at the say method, because
this now add one more
nuance to what we
want to do here.
And I think in interest of
making this go, let me
actually, since I'm not going
to get my machine to do this
right, let me create a
couple of professors.
If I look at what that is, it's
an MIT person because I
didn't have any separate string
thing there, and we
will create a more important
professor.
What rank do you want, John?
Do you want to stay full?
PROFESSOR 2: Undergraduate.
PROFESSOR: Undergraduate, right,
a lot more fun I agree.
Sorry about that, and we
can again just see
what that looks like.
And that of course,
we'll print out,
he's also an MIT person.
But now here's what
I want to do.
I want to say something
to my good
colleague Professor Guttag.
Actually I'm going to
start a separate --
I'm going to say something
to a smart undergraduate.
So if I say, remember we
have ug defined as an
undergraduate, let
me do something a
little different here.
Well let, me do it that way.
It says, I don't understand
why you say you
were enjoying 6.00.
Not a good thing to say, right,
but if I say to my good
colleague Professor Guttag.
I have to spell say right, I
know, I need help with this,
what can I say?
We flatter each other
all the time.
It's part of what makes us feel
good about ourselves.
Why is the sky blue?
I enjoyed your paper, but
why is the sky blue?
OK, terrible examples, but
what's going on here?
One more piece that
I want to add.
Here's my say method for
professor, and now I'm
actually taking advantage of to
whom I am saying something.
Notice again, what does it do?
There's the self argument,
that's just pointing to the
instance of me.
I'm passing in another argument,
going to call it to
who, in one case it was ug,
in one case it was Guttag.
And then the thing I want to
say, ah, look what it does, it
says, check the type.
And the type is going to take
that instance, I had an
instance, for example, of a
professor down here, and it's
going to pick up what type
of object it is.
So if the type of the person I'm
speaking to is undergrad,
let's pause for second.
Remember I started away back
saying we're building abstract
data types.
Well, here's a great example
of how I'm using
exactly that, right?
I've got int, I've got float,
I now have ug, it's a type.
So it's says if the object to
whom I'm speaking is an
undergrad, then use the same
method from person where I'm
going to put this
on the front.
On the other hand, if the object
to whom I'm speaking is
a professor, then I'm going to
tag this on the front and use
the underlying say method.
On the other hand, if I'm
speaking to somebody else, I'm
just going to go lecture.
All right, and when a professor
lectures, they just
put it's obvious on the
end of things, as
you may have noticed.
What's the point I want
you to see here?
I'm now using the instances
to help me to find what
the code should do.
I'm looking at the type.
If the type is this, do that.
If the type is this, do
something different, ok?
And I can now sort of build
those pieces up.
OK, I said one more class.
Notice what we're doing.
I know they're silly examples,
but, sorry, they are cleverly
designed examples to highlight
key points.
What I'm trying to do is show
you how we have methods
inherit methods, how have
message shadow methods, how we
have methods override methods,
how we can use instances as
types to define what the
method should do.
Let me show you one last class,
because I'm gonna have
one more piece that
we want to use.
And the last class is, sort of,
once you've got a set of
professors, you can have
an aggregate of them.
And I don't know, if a group of
geese are gaggle, I don't
know what a set of professors
are, John.
Flamers?
I, you know, we've got to figure
out what the right
collective noun here is.
We're going to call them a
faculty for lack of a better
term, right?
Now the reason I want to show
you this example is, this
class, notice, it only is going
to inherit from object.
It actually makes sense.
This is going to be a collection
of things, but it's
not a subclass of a particular
kind of person.
And what I want the faculty to
do, is to be able to gather
together a set of faculty.
So if I go down here, grab this
for second, and pull it
down so you can see it.
It looks like I'm not going to
be able to run this because my
machine is broken, but basically
I'm gonna define a
set of professors, and then I'm
gonna create a new class
called faculty.
There's the definition of it.
It's got an init.
You can kind of see
what it does.
It's going to set up an internal
variable called
names, which is initially an
empty list, internal variable
called ids, which is empty, an
internal variable called
members, which is empty, and
another special variable
called place, which we're going
to come back to in a
second, initially
bound to none.
OK, I've got a method called
add which I'm going to use
down here to add professors
to the course 6 faculty.
Here's what I want
to add to do.
First of all, notice I'm going
to check the type.
If this is not a professor, I'm
gonna raise an error, a
type error, it's the wrong type
of object to pass in.
The second thing I'm gonna do
is say, if that's okay, then
let me go off and get
the id number.
Now remember, that's right up
here, so I'm asking the
instance of the professor to go
up and get the id number.
And I want to make sure I only
have one instance of each
professor in my faculty, so if
the id number is in the list
of ids already, I'm going to
raise an error, sorry, raise
an exception as well, saying
I've got a duplicate id.
OK?
And the reason that's
going to come up is,
notice what I do now.
Inside of the instant self, I
take the variable names and I
add to it the family name of
the person I just added.
OK, notice the form.
I'm using the method, there's
the parens to get the family
name of the person.
I'm just adding it to the list.
I've got the id number,
I've added the ids,
and I add the
object itself into members.
So as I do this, what
am I doing?
I'm creating a list, actually
several lists: a list of ids,
a list of the actual instances,
and a list of the
family names.
And as a cost I want to add,
that's why I can check and
see, is this in here
already or not?
Now, the last reason I want to
do this is, I want to be able
to support things like that.
This is now different, right,
this instance is a collection.
I want to be able to do things
like, for all the things in
that collection, do something,
like print
out the family names.
And to do that, I need two
special forms: iter and next.
OK, now let me see if I
can say this cleanly.
Whenever I use a for, in
structure, even if it was on
just a normal list you built,
what Python is doing is
returning an, what is
called an iterator.
Which is something that
we talked earlier.
It's keeping track of where are
you in the list, and how
do I get to the next
thing in the list?
I'm going to do the same thing
here, and I'm going to create
it for this particular
structure.
So this little thing iter, when
I call a for something
in, one of these instances,
it calls iter, and
notice what it does.
It initializes place to 0.
That was that variable
I had up there.
That's basically saying I'm at
the beginning of the list.
It's a pointer to the beginning
of the list, and it
returns self.
Just gives me back a pointer
to the instance.
That now allows me at
each step in that
loop to call next.
And what does next do?
Next says, check to see if that
value is too long, if
it's longer than, for example,
the list of names, raise an
exception called stop iteration,
which the for loop
will use to say OK, I'm done.
I'm going to break out
of the for loop.
Otherwise, what am
I going to do?
I'll increment place by 1,
that's going to move me to the
next place in the list, and then
in this case I'll just
return the instance
itself, right?
Members is a list of instances,
place I've
incremented by 1, I take 1
off of it, I get to it.
So iter and next
work together.
Iter creates this method, that's
going to give you a
pointer to the place in the
structure, and then next
literally walks along the
structure giving you the next
element and returning elements
in turn so you can do
something with it.
Right, so now what that says
is, I can have classes that
just have local variables.
I can have classes that get
methods from other variables,
and I can also have classes
that are collections.
And I've supported that by
adding in this last piece.
OK once you have all of that,
in principle we could start
doing some fun things.
So let's see what happens
if we try and
make all of this go.
And let me, since I'm not going
to be able to run it,
let me simply do it this way.
If I have my undergraduate,
ug.
I can -- sorry, let's not
do it that way --
I can have undergraduate say
things like -- all right, what
did I just do wrong here?
Do I not have undergrad
defined?
I do.
Oh, I didn't have Grimson,
sorry, it's me, isn't it?
Thank you.
The undergraduate very politely
asks why he didn't
understand, you can have
the professor respond.
Again, it simply puts a
different thing into there.
On the other hand, if Professor
Guttag asks me
something about understanding, I
say I really like this paper
on, you do not understand,
it's a deep paper on
programming languages 5, I
think, John, isn't it?
What else can you do with
this thing, right?
You can have an undergraduate
talk to an undergraduate, in
which case they're
still polite.
Or you could have -- sorry, let
me do that the other way
-- you could also have an
undergraduate simply talk to a
normal person.
All right, but the good news is
you know eventually you get
it done, and when you're really
done you can have the
undergraduate be really happy
about this, and so she sings
to herself.
OK it's a little silly, but
notice what we've just
illustrated.
And this is where I want
to pull it together.
With a simple set of classes,
and the following abilities,
an ability to inherit methods
from subclasses, sorry from
superclasses, that is having
this hierarchy of things.
I can create a fairly complex
kind of interaction.
I can take advantage of the
types of the objects to help
me decide what to do.
And if you think about that,
I know it sounds very
straightforward, but you would
do exactly that if you were
writing earlier code to deal
with some numerical problem.
All right, if the thing is an
integer, do this, if it's a
float, do that, if it's a
string, do something else.
I'm now giving you exactly the
same ability, but the types
now can be things that
you could create.
And what I've also got is now
the ability to inherit those
methods as they go
up the chain.
So another way of saying it is,
things that you want to
come away from here, are, in
terms of these classes.
We now have this idea
of encapsulation.
I'm gathering together data that
naturally belongs as a
unit, and I'm gathering together
with it methods that
apply to that unit.
Just like we would have done
with float or int.
Ideally, we data hide, we don't
happen to do it here,
which is too bad.
Basically we've got the
idea of encapsulation.
The second thing we've got is
this idea of inheritance.
Inheritance both meaning
I can inherit
attributes or field values.
I can inherit methods by
moving up the chain.
I can also the shadow or
override methods, so that I
can specialise.
And I do all of that with this
nice hierarchy of classes.
So what hopefully you've seen,
between these two lectures,
and we're going to come back
to it in some subsequent
lectures, is that this is now
a different way of just
structuring a computational
system.
Now, you'll also get arguments,
polite arguments
from faculty members or other
experts about which is a
better way of doing it.
So I'll give you my bias,
Professor Guttag will give you
his bias next time around.
My view, object-oriented system
are great when you're
trying to model systems that
consist of a large number of
units that interact in
very specific ways.
So, modeling a system of
people's a great idea.
Modeling a system of molecules
is probably a great idea.
Modeling a system where it is
natural to associate things
together and where the number
of interactions between them
is very controlled.
These systems work
really well.
And we'll see some examples
of that next week.
Thanks.